Finding long lost relatives can be really tricky, especially if you don't
have a good place to start, but it's a lot easier if you
have the help from someone like a Genetic Genealogist, and today we lucky
enough to be joined remotely with CC Moore, a Genetic Genealogist. Hi CC.
>> Hi Matt, how are you?
>> I'm doing pretty good, you know we pretty excited to be learning all
about this Ancestry and Human Evolution, and
we're really curious at this point. You know,
what is it that a genetic genealogist does?
>> A genetic genealogist uses DNA testing in
conjunction with traditional genealogy research in order to
learn more about our roots. And so, does this mean that you have to go through
a service like 23 and me, a similar
service like Family Tree, dna.com, what do you
need as an individual who is interested in
finding out more along the lines of genetic genealogy?
>> Well you need to take a direct-to-consumer genetic genealogy test.
So yes, that can be 23 and me, Ancestry DNA, or Family
Tree DNA. Also, also National Geographic Genome 2.0, although that's more
focused on ancient ancestry, then it is applicable to our family trees.
>> I see, and how do, how do you get in touch with people? How do
you interact with people, do they come to
you with questions, do you help them find relatives?
>> We have a very active genetic genealogy
community. We have have lots of forums and mailing
lists and there's people posting questions and answers
all day long on these lists. So that the
best way to, get involved and really learn
how we're using DNA testing for geneaology. Also, to
get answers from a lot of the experts. We
have really an amazing community with incredibly intelligent and
knowledgeable people who are willing to help for free on these lists.
So that's really how I would recommend getting started. You know, sign up,
take the test with one of the companies, and while you're waiting for
your results, get on one of the lists and start learning right away.
>> Now, what kind of consumers end up
interested in this kind of thing? Do you find
mainly just people with a generic interest, or
do you find a lot of, maybe adopted individuals?
>> I think all of the above. When we
first started with Genetic Genealogy the early adopters were
highly educated. A lot of times retired scientists of
not geneticists but other types of scientists, and professionals
from other industries, and now as we've gone further
with it and it's gotten more visibility, it among
the general populace. We have a lot more people
coming in from all walks of life, all different
types of jobs, different ages and certainly
adoptees. Because DNA testing for an adoptee
is just a revelation, especially for one
who had no knowledge of their biological roots.
>> Now that raises an interesting question I think for
me and other people is, we don't often put a
lot of thought into the considerations, ethical or otherwise, even
just emotional or psychological. What are some of the important aspects
that you think people should be
thinking about whenever they're approaching this idea
of finding family members, and trying to reach out and grow their family?
>> I always say expect unexpected surprises. I give a lot of
speeches about genetic genealogy, and I've
incorporated that in every one now, and
lots of my writings about genetic genealogy as well. And that's because my
experience has been that you just don't know what you're going to find.
There have been a tremendous number of people who have
found close family members who had no idea that that
other person existed. So, be prepared. And if you are
not prepared to learn the truth, then you probably shouldn't test.
>> I see. Now, that makes it sound very interesting. I
take it not all the responses or reactions are always positive.
>> The vast majority have been positive. But,
sometimes it just takes time getting used to.
When you don't know that you have a half
sibling or a child out there sometimes. Or a
first cousin, nephew. Aunt, uncle, all of these types
of relationships have been discovered. It's a shock, of
course, I've been, been a part of a lot
of great reunions where everyone was thrilled to meet
each other. But you know, it's not an easy
thing to add a new family member. Especially someone
so close.
>> Is there any particular relationship that you help
people find or that you just find that other
people end up discovering on their own that seems
to be more profound than other kinds of relationships?
>> I think a parent-child relationship is the most
profound one you can find. particularly a mother, though I
think it's also true for fathers. But when mothers
have carried a child for nine months and then given
it up for adoption, it's an extremely emotional thing
to rediscover that person. So, I think it does take
a lot of, adapting. Sometimes those birth mothers have been
searching for their child they gave up for decades. And,
or even if they weren't searching or was hoping
that that child would find them. And so they're thrilled
but a lot of times they already have another family.
So they have a husband and they have children, and
they don't always know about the existence of
that other family member. So it takes a
little bit of time and sensitivity to integrate
that new family member. I, I have not
actually personally seen any negative responses from birth
mothers or children being reunited. There have been
some birth fathers who didn't know of the
child's existence. Who have had a harder time accepting
the truth of it. And if they don't understand genetics
and they don't understand, you know, the test that we're using,
I think sometimes it's hard to convince these people that
yes, this is your child. And I have been a part
of a situation where the father denied, the birth father
denied at the time that he could have been the father
and that's partly why the child was given up for
adoption. And when this adoptee found a match at 23 and
me which turned out to be a paternal aunt,
he was still unable to accept the truth of this.
Although the whole extended family has now accepted that
this adoptee into their family. And one of the really
interesting things about that case is, I used the
MT DNA and the X chromosome inheritance in order to
narrow down exactly what the relationship was between these
people because they shared, I think it was 28% about,
of their DNA. So as you know there could
be a couple of different relationships in this case.
And by looking at the X chromosome inheritance, we
were able to narrow it down and say that this
is definitely a paternal aunt and she had her
other brother test. So also paternal uncle, we confirmed
it. And the father still denied it, the birth
father, so they hired a geneticist to look over it.
And he thought that I was being too specific
with my claim but I think that's because he
doesn't understand how we're using DNA testing for genealogy
and for these adoption searches. And so later when
we found the birth mother. Which we found when
she transferred her raw data to family tree DNA's
family finder. Believe it or not we found a
maternal first cousin. So in half an hour I
was able to locate the birth mother. And
when she was contacted, she confirmed that the person
we had identified as the birth father was indeed,
and they have gone to the same college, same
year, I mean it was very clear. So, that
case, has mostly turned out great, she's had a
wonderful reunion with her mother and with her paternal
extended family, but the father still has never admitted
that he is indeed the father. So, it's sensitive, yeah.
>> Yeah, I mean it seems amazing,
I mean the, obviously the, the information is
very powerful. The, the, the genetic tracing.
I'm curious to know from your perspective, do
you ever, what percentage of people do you think sign up for these 23 and
me services, and don't quite know that they're
getting themselves into a paternity test of sorts.
is that common, or, or uncommon?
>> I think most people don't realize the
power of these types of tests. there's different
reasons that people test. As you know, they
might be testing for health reasons, if it's
23 and Me, whereas they might not realize
the genealogical implications. And it's not always that
a match finds their birth parent there, with
an adoptee, for instance. Or a donor-conceived individual.
We may find a more distant relative that they're
related to, and still be able to triangulate this
adoptees matches, and identify the probable birth parents. So,
you could be identified, even if you don't test.
And I think that is just something that our
society is going to have to get used to.
it's just the way things are going and I
believe very strongly in truth. I'm not a scientist by,
training, but science is about truth, and
I don't think that, it's something that
we should deny. It's something that we
should definitely be moving towards and knowledge
is power so, hopefully, everyone will agree with me and get tested and not be
upset if they get contacted by a family member that they didn't know about.
>> Exactly. We are definitely in the new
information age. where all of this can really change
our outlooks and our family structures in lots of different ways.
What you know, for those of us. I, I, I sort
of just realized, for those of us who don't know very
much about genealogy at all, how, how far out do you go
in a family structure as a genetic genealogist? Are you interested
in, you know, up to grandparents and maybe second cousins, or
do, do, do you build out farther than that? Do you
connect whole families? Kind of just give us some idea of how
far out you go?
>> Well, we're interested in our family trees as
far back as we can go, so with Y
DNA testing which has been used in genetic genealogy
much longer than autosomal DNA tests like 23 and
me. We're looking way back. We could be looking
back into the 1400's even, because as you know
the Y chromosome changes very slowly. Therefore a father
and son will probably have an identical Y chromosome.
And maybe a grandparent and a great grandparent, a
second great grandfather on that direct paternal line. So
we've used this surname studies to go many, many
generations back. centuries back. With autosomal DNA, we're not
looking quite so far back because of the recombination.
However, when we first started using autosomal DNA for
genetic geneaology, we were told that it was only
going to work maybe five generations, six generations back.
And especially with our adoption DNA research
we have proven that it works much further
back. We're able to identify ancestral couples,
a couple centuries ago actually in these, trees
and the way we do that is for instance if an adoptee knows nothing about
their biological heritage. We would take all
of their family trees of their DNA matches,
so everyone who's willing to share at 23 and
Me, or Family Tree DNA, or Ancestry DNA. And we
would start comparing those trees, looking for commonalities and intersections
among their matches' trees, since they don't know anything about
their family tree. And if we see a certain
ancestral couple over and over and over and over, we
can be pretty sure that that's probably one of their
ancestors as well, and if not their ancestor, certainly in
an ancestral line. One of their branches of
their family tree would have that ancestral line in
it. And we've used couples very far back, like,
late 1600s, 1700s, and been able to build down
to the present time. That takes a lot of
work, believe me. And we wouldn't just do it
with one couple, we would do it with various
couples, build their descendants down to the present, and
try to see where there's intersections between the
descendants from those ancestral couples. And if we can
do that, which we sometimes can, we can
sometimes solve this adoption search cases without a close
relative match. If we get second cousin or
closer, we can almost always solve it. if we're
only working with third cousins, fourth cousins, fifth
cousins and more distant, it takes a lot more
work, but it has been done.
>> That's really amazing. you know, we have,
an individual in our course named Sterling, who
is actually submitted his DNA sample to 23
and Me and gotten results back. And he
has been able to find a, as close a match as a second cousin on the relative
finder. Now, if you were chatting with him and he was looking for a next step,
what advice would you give to him to sort of deal with trying to reach out
to that person or possibly, you know, finding
other connections that he could get more information from.
>> There's a couple different things he should do. First of all, he
may want to join one of our adoption DNA mailing lists. We have
extremely helpful search angels on those
lists who started out as traditional adoption
search angels. So they know how to work with the records. And if
he has any non-identifying information, that can really help to
use that in conjunction with his DNA results. So we can
help to teach him on those lists what he needs
to do next. And sometimes, you know, do more than just
teach him, but hand-hold. And if he gets real close
to the answer, one of the search angels will jump in
and help. And when I say real close, a second
cousin is really close. So he probably could find someone who'd
be willing to help him work through this matches and
try to identify his birth parents. And the way we would
do that is, we would take that second cousin match
you happen to know what the percentage is that's in common?
>> I believe it's, it's around, I think its above 1% ish?
>> Okay, so, we would look at the percent, and
try to determine if it's a solid second cousin match, or
if it might be a second cousin once removed,
or third cousin. So if his match is around 1%,
that could be a second cousin, it could be
a second cousin once removed. Could be a third cousin.
Could be a first cousin twice removed. depending on
the different ages. So we would look at all of
those possibilities, and we would want that matches family
tree back to great grandparents or preferably great, great grandparents.
Because they may if they are true seconds cousins they
will share great grandparents, but if they're second cousins once removed
it might be his great, great-grandparent, and their great-grandparent, or the
other way around. Or if there's a bunch a removals, it
could even be a little further back in the tree.
So as much as we can get of that family tree,
built from traditional genealogy, we want. If his match doesn't have
it, then we would build that for them. So then we
would look at all of those great-grandparents first. And we would
build, towards the present with their descendants. And we would try
to find somebody in the right place at the right time
who could be this adoptee's birth parent. So we don't know if
it's going to be the mother or the father. So we'd have
to look at both in this case. If it's an adoptee who
already knows their birth mother, which happens quite a bit, now
we know we're just looking for a male in the right place
at the right time, of the right age, to
be their birth parent. And if we don't find
anyone from those great grand parents descendants, we have
to go back one generation. And go to great, great
grandparents and try building them, to the present. And
if we still have trouble, what I would do
is start looking at his other matches. Preferably his
next closest matches, but all of his matches are important.
And, we build spreadsheets. So, this is a little
complicated. But, this is what we do. We get
all of the matching segment data into a spreadsheet
and we sort it. So it's in order. Chromosome one,
start with the beginning of the chromosome to the
end of the chromosome, so, one base pair all
the way out to the very end, 230,000, whatever
it is. And we go to the next one, and
chromosome two, three, four, five, and then we start
looking at people who are overlapping. On these matching segments.
And we try to find groups of people who all
would match each other. Now we since we know that
there's two chromosomes in each spot, right, it might look
like they're matching, but they're not So we have to
then triangulate, meaning do in common with, if it's Family
Tree DNA, they have a feature where you can compare
the matches and see if they match, or 23andMe, it's
even better because we can actually compare them to see if
they match on the same spot. So if I'm sharing
with someone and sharing with someone else, I can compare them.
So, then we break those groups up into a paternal
and maternal chromosome. And we don't usually know which is paternal
which is maternal, so we just call them A and B.
So, we will have chromosome one A and chromosome one B.
And we'll have groups of overlapping matches. Now
what would we would do is try to
get the family tree information, the regular genealogy
that, of, from documentary research. And compare these family
trees, of the matches since the adoptee doesn't
have one, and we look for commonalities and
overlaps. So if we can find an ancestral
couple that appears in some of these overlapping matches
then we know that that also has to be in
the adoptee's family tree, and why is that? That's because
each piece of DNA can only come from one of
our ancestors right? Now its probably an ancestral couple, so
we won't know if it's from the man or the
woman of the couple, but that's okay, because we know
that this couple then, goes in their family tree. And
in this way, we can give adoptees their family tree back
piece by piece. So even if we can't automatically
tell them who their birth parents are, we can start
giving them pieces of their heritage back. Which is incredibly
meaningful for adoptees I found. I think it's hard for
those of us who aren't adopted to understand that,
but I've had a lot of adoptees say to me,
I have ancestors. Like it's so strange for them to
know that they have ancestors. And this also works well
for African Americans who can't get their genealogy,
past slavery. I've been able to identify a lot
of their European ancestors by doing this. And
we don't know where they fit in the tree
yet, so they're just sort of floating around
in space you know, not connected to which branch
of the tree, but eventually, if you keep
doing this, you'll be able to attach these ancestors
to the correct branches of the trees.
So it's really fascinating and exciting for genealogists,
adoptees, and anyone who has unknown parentage, to
discover these things that they didn't know about.
>> I love it. That was a great answer. I mean, it
sounds like so much work, but it sounds like it really pays off
to everyone involved. you get a lot of information, there is a
lot of value in that and sort of re-establishing your, your identify and
your family structure. You know, I have to ask
I've never met anybody who is so confident in
their ability to actually say second cousin once removed,
third cousin twice removed. You know, in just my
preparation for this course, you know, I, I, I
got, tried to get back into understanding those different
relationships. How long did it take you to actually,
learn all those different, cousin relationships and does it make
sense to you?
>> It does. And as a genealogist, that's something
we deal with anyway But I don't think I have
a really strong confident grasp on it until I
started doing genetic genealogy, and it's so important for autosomal
DNA because its going to half with, you know
the amount of DNA we expect to see on average
in common is going to half with each removal.
So you have to understand that that the second cousin
is going to have an average of expected DNA
of 3.125%. I've seen it down to about 1% and
I've seen it up to almost 5%. So there is
this huge range. But if it's the second cousin once
removed we're only expecting to see about half of that.
So about 1.6%. You really have to get a grasp
on it if you're going to do this work. Now
there's charts that we have on our, International Society of
Genetic Genealogists, I helped to found the wiki in 2010.
So we have the charts on there. If you ask on
one of the lists, someone will help you with that.
It's also on my blog. So the information's out there. You
don't have to have it memorized. And I do have
it memorized because I've done it so much. But it's still
get overwhelming and I, someone writes me and says, help
me figure this out. I think I have a first cousin
once removed. I'm still sitting there like writing it down
on paper. You know because it helps so much to
be able to visualize it and get it there. And
like okay this person's descended from this person, there must be
two people in between, and here's the matches' family tree
and count back and, you know, it does get confusing.
So you just have to be really organized about it
and use all the resources available that we have out there.
>> Sure, and I'm, I'm a very
visual person too. So when I think about it, it
definitely helps to see the graph in front of me
or, or be able to see those connections. Now, we've
skirted around it and you just mentioned it there, you actually,
run a very popular blog called Your Genetic Genealogist. And
I'd love for you to tell us a little bit more
about how you, you started that blog and what it
means to you and, and what people use it for today.
>> I guess that means I have
to start at the beginning a little bit
which is that I was a genealogist, just hobbyist.
And I've always loved genetics. It's not my career
in the past, I wasn't trained in it, but
I've always been drawn into it, I always
really loved it. And so, when autosomal DNA was,
introduced for genealogical purposes, by 23 and me, I
jumped in with both feet, I was so excited.
it was actually Katherine Borges who was the director of
ISOGG, who first showed me what they were doing, and
I just fell madly in love and it completely took
over my life. So, it went from being a hobby
to a full time volunteer position and now a career,
and part of that was starting my blog. I was
answering a lot of questions all the time, of people
who needed help right away. And so, I wanted a way
to be able to answer those questions, and not
have to keep repeating the same answers over and over.
I was also doing some really fascinating research with my
own family and wanted to have a place to write
that up. And I was corresponding with 23 and Me
a lot. People who worked over there. Right away, I
established a good relationship with them, and it was actually
one of them who recommended that I start a blog.
It was Alex from 23 and Me. He's not there
anymore, but he was one of the early, employees there, and
he said, you know, you should write a blog. And
so, I'd never done anything like that. And I enjoyed it,
right off the bat. It was so fun to share
my research, and get input from everybody. And help people learn
what to do with their results as well. And it's
grown into something I never could've imagined. Looking at my analytics,
it's just amazing. Almost from the very beginning there was people from
Stanford, and Harvard, and governmental agencies reading it. universities
all over the world, so it just literally blew my mind. I mean I thought
I would just have a few genealogists reading it,
but I think it was the right time, the
right thing at the right time. There weren't many
blogs. Blaine Bettinger, the genetic genealogist, had been writing
since 2007, but he was really the only one doing it, and he's an
attorney, so he was pretty busy and wasn't writing as much, so there was a
real opening for me. So it was one of those niche things that just worked
out, and turned out to do this amazing thing that I never could have planned.
>> Well I know so many people are
happy that you started, including us. we're actually
going to use it as a resource for our
students, who are really interested in the topic. So
I hope that they'll, all you students out there will make good use of that.
now what I'd love to do is actually pivot a little bit now, and we'll talk
about sort of the, sort of more career side of this. As, as you sort of gotten
into explaining a bit how you, how you got to this point. Now, you mentioned.
>> Could I add one thing about my blog? Sorry to interrupt.
>> Sure.
>> I just wanted to say. So, early on, I started asking
relatives to test. Right away, I realized that that
was going to add a lot to my research. So now
I have about 35, 40, pretty close family members tested.
But on my blog I started a second cousin study.
So every time I would test a second cousin
I would write up the results from that. And I
would show the range of sharing. Sometimes it's low, sometimes
it's high. But the exciting thing about it for genealogists
was, I started talking about how when you test
a second cousin you can identify the DNA that
you receive from each of your great grandparent ancestral
couples. And that's an exciting thing for a genealogist
because we have spent thousands and thousands of hours
researching these people. And great grandparents aren't that far
back, they're not that far out of our reach.
But most of us never got to meet them.
And of course we know that they are inside of
us, but we've never had tangible evidence of it before.
So to be able to say look, on chromosome ten,
from one million to 20 million, I know I got
this DNA from my proctor great grandparents on my mom's
side. And my allen great grandparents on my dad's side.
To me that was fascinating, it sounds sort of like
nerdy, techy. But, for genealogist it really has been meaningful.
And I think it's just going to get more meaningful as
we learn more about genetics. I mean, we all know
how fast genetics is advancing. So I think that will
start to mean a lot to us in real life. We'll
be able to say, hey you know, I know I
have that DNA in that area from this particular great
grandparent or great great grandparent depending how far back you've
been able to trace it. And that means that I got,
say, the shape of my nose, for instance. I'm
just making this up. But you know, but that particular
gene. From those, specific ancestors. And so for those of
us who just love our ancestors, and would dig in
dusty boxes for hours on end to find tiny
little tidbits, this is extremely meaningful for us. So I
think that's why Genetic Genealogy, in part, why it has
exploded the way it has. For our group, our community.
>> Yeah. I, I completely. I, I completely
agree, you know, in lesson 11 for our course,
we actually go over an example where you have
grandchildren who have blue eyes, and both parents have
brown eyes, and the question is, is, in general
eye color is controlled by several genes but a
couple of really important ones. And we can actually
exactly trace which grandparent and which grandparent that eye
color gene came from. Which grandparent gave you that allele,
you can trace it all the way back. And it really
is fascinating. It gives you a new idea instead of this,
sort of mysterious, oh I know I got this from my
great grandparents but I don't know which one or, even
on which side, and you're like I know my great aunt,
you know, my, my great grandmother Norma, gave me my blue
eyes. And it just gives you a new sense of identity.
>> Exactly. I'm so happy to hear that,
because I always talk about that in my speeches. But
I'm, like I said, I'm not a geneticist, so I
don't know the exact genes that are, you know, controlling
each of these traits. But I know that some of
the information is out there, and all the time there's
more and more, and more. because Ann Wojciciki from 23andme
has this slide she shows in her presentations where she
say's what we knew a couple of years ago. And it's
just like a few dots here and there across the genome and what we know now,
like what's been identified. To be significant. And
it's just full of them now. So all though
that that's not my area of expertise. I know that this is meaningful and is just
going to get more and more so. So
hearing that from you just confirms what I thought.
>> Great, I'm glad to hear that. Well you
know? We're really intriged that you say, you know,
genetics is a passion of yours but it wasn't actually
what you studied. Can you tell us a bit more about
what you did before you got into this and sort
of what your segue was. Were you just a super, super
nerd spend all your free time in genetics. Or was
this just a, a really fun hobby for you. Genetics was
always something that I was interested in, but I had
not studied it. In fact, I was a music and theater
major in college, and I had fallen in love with genetics
just prior to that in my senior year in high school
when I was in AP bio. We had a little genetics,
section as part of our course work. And I absolutely loved
it. So I should have taken the clue then. And I,
I loved it enough that I did think about changing my
major. And I even investigated it. But I already had a
scholarship for music at USC, and they didn't have a genetics,
undergraduate program or I very well may have done
it. But I just stuck with my original plan
and many years later, here I end up back
again loving genetics, but this time it took over my
life. So I had started as a genealogist in
2002, I think was when I really got involved,
and I was looking at making a family tree
for my niece's wedding. And I, the type of person
who jumps in with both feet. And I did
that and, got kind of obsessed. did genealogy for a few
years before I got really interested in the genetics
part of it. we, we're just using Y-DNA and mtDNA
at the time, which I still thought was interesting.
But I wasn't quite as fascinated as I am with
autosomal DNA. And that's really become my focus although
I use the other types in conjunction with it many
times especially in adoption searches. So how did
I get into it? So I started writing the
blog. And I got so many questions from
people, and so much interest, that it literally started
taking over my life. I had tons of comments on the blog, I had tons of private
emails of people wanting help, particularly people who
were searching for close family members like adoptees, and
people who had discovered close family members, and hadn't expected
it. there's so many people out there that this is
happening to, you'd be surprised. And I sometimes wonder if
there's much more of that in our society than we realize,
but then I think that it's also possible that the
people who are drawn to testing, are the people who maybe
felt a little different, or felt like something was missing
in their lives. So it's hard to say which it is.
But anyway, the result was, that I was
completely overwhelmed. So I had been an actress,
for many years, and then when I had
my son, I had transitioned behind the camera, and
was producing commercials. And my poor partner has
had to completely take over our production business because
I work about 18 hours a day, 7 days a week doing genetic genealogy. And I never
would have imagined it would have become my career. I
don't have a science background, I've certainly taken science classes
and always loved them, but that wasn't the direction I
took with my career. So to go from entertainment and
to end up in a science career in my forties
is definitely not something I would have ever imagined. But
it is so fascinating. Everyday, I wake up in the
morning and I immediately want to jump out of bed and
run down to my computer and see what
new fascinating things had tra, have transpired overnight and,
believe me, there is always something. I'm very
involved with all of the genetic genealogy mailing lists.
So I spend a lot of time answering
questions on those. And I do help adoptees for
free. So a lot of my time is spent
as a volunteer. I do some consulting. But probably
the most amazing thing that's come from it
is, I am now the Genetic Genealogy Consultant
on Finding Your Roots with Henry Louis Gates
Jr. and also Genealogy Roadshow. And there's also
another Fox pilot, which I don't know if anything will come of it. So, there are
currently three television shows that I am doing
consulting for. And, so now, my entertainment background, and
this new career, that I never planned on, have
kind of come together in a way I would never
have imagined. So it's been quite a ride. I mean,
amazing. They say sometimes you just fall into something. And
I wish I'd fallen into it in my twenties, but
still great that I eventually got where I am now.
what do you think about the current state of genetic
genealogists in the country, or in the world? Do you
think that we're in need of, of more people who can
serve the same kind of role you and your blog serve?
>> Yeah. That's a terrific question, Matt, and
it is something that I think about every
day. Because I have so many people coming to me for help, I can't possibly help
them all. I stay up all hours of the night and I, you know, don't do
a lot of, social activities so I can
help these people. It's really fulfilling. And I prioritize
the ones who have a really emotionally important question.
Like they have discovered something of great significance to
their, close family. And I just can't keep up
with it. And I need people that are doing what
I'm doing that I can send these people to.
And I have a couple colleagues that I am able
to refer people to and there's a great network
of search angels who have learned to do genetic genealogy.
Who are also helping adoptees and those like
them who have an unknown parentage, usually unknown father,
sometimes donor-conceived individuals. But it's even more than
just that. I have a lot of, just you
know, people interested in their ancestry and in
their genealogy. Who are either are genealogists or aren't
and are just interested in learning more, because
they've heard about DNA testing. There's such a huge
demand for this. And maybe a year ago, some
people had come to me and asked me you
know, if they wanted to have a career in
Genetic Genealogy, was there was there a demand for it?
And it's changed. Really then, maybe a year ago,
two years ago, there wasn't much of a demand
for it. And in the last year or two,
it has literally exploded. So now I absolutely would say
that there is room for genetic genealogy consultants. People who
are willing to learn what we're doing. And if they
have a background in genealogy that would be great. And
if they don't that's fine too. They'll have to learn both
sides of it. So they'll have to learn the DNA
part and the genealogy part. But if they're adventurous and
they're looking for a new career and they love detective
work because that's exactly what this is. Then I would strongly
recommend that they look into this as a career.
>> Well, great. Sort of as our parting words here in, in the
same vein is there any other specific advice or resources you would give to
someone who's particularly moved by this
subject and wants to investigate about the
possibility of studying more? Are there some places they can go to? Sort of
[COUGH]
learn more about how to become a genetic genealogist that you recommend?
>> Yes. Because the field is so fast
moving there are very few books that really address
the subject. And every day we have someone asking,
you know, is there are genetic genealogy for dummies
book. And there isn't. Not yet at least.
And that's because those of us who've tried to
write them find that they are so quickly outdated.
That trying to get something published is very difficult,
that's up to date. So we always recommend that
you read the blogs. You read my blog, Blaine's
blog, Rebre-, Roberta Estes blog. There's some other really
good ones out there. Kitty Cooper has recently started
writing some fantastic resources. And most of all, join
our mailing list, because that's where you really get
help from the experts. And the people who've been
doing this from the very beginning are very generous
with their time, and they're on those lists. So
join the International Society of Genetic Genealogy. It's free.
It's ISOGG, isogg.org. And then you'll get an invitation
to join the DNA newbie list which I happen
to administer, and you can go there and ask
the most basic questions. and we have people who've
been on the list for quite a while, so
we also have more intermediate discussions and sometimes even
venture into more advanced. So, just keep reading everything you can.
That's how I learned this. I got on the list and
I made myself read every single message, whether it made sense
to me or not, and it didn't at first. But I think
it works like you know, osmosis for a lack of a
better word. It starts to seep in after a while and
it starts to make sense, and you don't even know how
that happened because it, you didn't even know what you were reading.
But our brains work, you know, mysterious ways.
And, I, I promise you, if you get on
the list and you read everything that everyone's writing,
especially people like Ann Turner, who was one of
the first pioneer genetic genealogists, and she wrote the
book Tracing Your Roots with DNA. And she's on
those lists. I mean, you can't access a better
resource than her, and a lot of my other
colleagues, Tim Jansen is amazing, he's on those
lists. So join us, and we'll help you learn.
>> Great. CC, it's been a pleasure chatting with you. I hope
you'll join us again maybe in the discussion forums for our course.
>> That'll be great. I'd love to.